aber wer jetzt was macht bei der
Ampel das ist die das war neuer
Thema bei mir in meiner Stammkneipe
in Ascheberg und dann schaffenberg im
Schlappeseppel und da bin ich
rein und kam da einer gesagt
wir machen wir haben gerade Pub Quiz es geht um
die Ampel und da ist die Frau wer macht was wer
hat auf welchem Ministerium du weißt sowas doch
oder du bist unser Mann also das mache ich euch
im Schlaf wenn ich sie und dann kam ich doch
ins Grübeln bei der FDP also im Moment mal
logisch dann also der der mehrfach bleibt
die Lindner ist Finanz weil Fachkompetenz
Verkehr ist der Wirsing wir singen Entschuldigung
obwohl aber ganz ehrlich ich hätte ja
nie für möglich gehalten und danach
all diesen CSU Giganten auf dem Posten das war
irgendwann mal eine kommt der ist noch schlimmer
aber es geht nicht
schöne ist es geht und der hat auch gewarnt
im Auftrag seines Herrn was die EU davor hat
ein aus des verbrennermotors ab 2035 das
geht überhaupt nicht weil dann haben wir
Journalisten geworden weil warum weil
ja weil das sind ja warum denn weil und
wenn dann gar kein Argument dann ist klar
was kommt passt gefährdet Arbeitsplätze
wir brauchen doch weniger Verbrenner wir müssen
doch Öl sparen wie die Blöden nach dem um Putin
endgültig in die Knie zu zwingen nicht nur im
Verkehr überall auch zu Hause Heizung runterdrehen
ohne Ende das hat uns alt Bundespräsident
Joachim Gauck in diesem Jahr doch auch vorgeladen
wir alle müssen frieren für
den Frieden außerhalb Jockel
es lässt sich leicht verkünden ne wenn er
bequem in seiner Folge dämmten und gut geheizten
altbundes Präsidenten Wohnung überhaupt und sich
weder um Strom Heizkosten Gedanken machen muss
weil der Staat alles bezahlt viele Leute sind
ja Zustände wie bei einem Hartz IV Empfänger
hey komm
da wird ja vor der stillen Zeit die starre Zeit
die so mag noch ein Thema gerade so abgeräumt
der Streit um das Bürgergeld nach Hartz IV
heißt jetzt ab Januar Bürgergeld bleibt aber
im Wesentlichen eigentlich Hartz IV hatte heißt
jetzt fix sonst ändert sich groß nix na und damit
war die Union zufrieden wir haben das Schlimmste
verhindert sondern ja um die Menschen ging es ja
gar nicht die vertrauenszeit war zu lang und
ist schon Vermögen viel zu hoch was für eine
gespensterdiskussion der arbeitslos gewordene
Lagerist verheiratet zwei Kinder hätte sein
schon Vermögen von 150.000 Euro womit auch
immer er sich das hätte er schonen können
bei aufgestockte Mindestlohn der hätte
es doch tatsächlich zwei Jahre lang nicht
antasten müssen einige haben sich dann
gewundert bei der Verhandlung in der
verschlossenen Türen wo ist 150.000
Euro das gilt schon als Vermögen
geh für 150.000 Euro da gehe ich für einen
mastendeal von Niedermeier ans Telefon
größtes Auge zeigte sich natürlich wieder
dauervordere Söder breitbeinig wie immer
weil das Lohnabstandsgebot nicht mehr stimmt
allgemein das Bürgergeld benachteiligt die
unteren Einkommensgruppen die hat arbeiten müssen
Kassiererinnen Busfahrer Polizeimeister die jeden
Tag versuchen irgendwie über die Runden zu kommen
wenn Polizisten die für uns täglich
den Kopf Inhalten finanziell nur knapp
über die Runden kommen dann mach
halt was dann änder was dran Du
bist doch der Chef du bist doch der
Ministerpräsident zack zack hör auf
Zahl ihnen Zahl Ihnen ein vernünftiges Gehalt
damit das Lohnabstandsgebot wieder stimmt
überhaupt worüber reden wir uns eigentlich auf
na der gesamten unteren Hälfte der Bevölkerung
also rund 30 Millionen Menschen gehören gerade mal
1,4 Prozent des Gesamtvermögens 1,4 ein bisschen
mehr als ein Prozent der gesamten unteren Hälfte
dagegen gehört dem einen reichsten Prozent mehr
als ein Drittel habe ich mich gewundert dazu hat
man von den wackeren Christdemokraten die beim
Bürgergeld das Schlimmste verhindert haben nichts
gehört was würden die wohl heute zum Heiligen
Sankt Martin sagen wie konnte der so blöd sein und
seinen Mantel Teilen im November da ist doch kalt
und dann kommt er mit seinem Pferd unter
versperrt ihm ein Bettler den Weg einen
nichtsnutzt eingehüllt in Lumpen und Decken dem
geht man nicht die Hälfte von seinem Mantel dem
nimmt man zuerst mal die Decke weg damit
man damit später sein Pferd wärmen kann
so wird dieser Nichtsnutz wieder zur Arbeit
angehalten das gibt dem Selbstwertgefühl würde
und Eigenverantwortung zurück ja sozial sein heißt
Kälte auszuhalten indem man sich anstrengt um sie
ihn Wärme für die Gemeinschaft zu verwandeln
ich weiß wovon ich rede ich habe einen Gestüt
bei mir ist noch keiner hervor schon
gar kein Camp aber ich war noch